when I read you something from one of
these testimonials I'm doing these
groups for 40 years
with Multicultural groups for you know
all over the world for 40 years Ellen
you know that right
here's Duty she says um
our conscious conversation simply and
gently yet profoundly revealed the truth
that all of humanity has been seeking
forever
in just a few minutes
this very pointed our awareness to
awareness itself the illusion of
Separation began to dissolve
my sense of having a separate body
melted in the warm delicious energy that
engulfed the whole group
thought had no power and floated by like
clouds emotions transformed into what I
experienced to be the empty fullness
spoken of by the sages or eternal love
itself
the embodiment of what cannot be
adequately spoken of happened
it was Blissful and once experienced
nothing can or ever will be the same
this is life this is a life-changing
event
yeah
that's beautiful
I feel like I'm really gonna like Eddie
and Eddie
um
in many ways is probably fully stepped
into whatever the unique expression is
and for this here uh has went through a
lot of stilling itself repeatedly in the
last year and Beyond just to just be
nobody learn to not be anyone learn to
be space learn to be loved learn to be
that really first fully yeah and then
now
Express now be space expressing itself
to itself for waking up and healing and
loving and meeting basic needs and all
this good stuff yeah and that I think
that's an that's a crucial thing is to
jump too quickly into the expression is
to allow potentially a little bit of
egoism to reside in that and so there's
a really deep importance to the process
of purification
uh into that spaciousness to that air to
that love that then makes the expression
more pure at least that's what I felt in
my direct experience so it's been really
really beautiful well I couldn't that's
the emptiness the void that is has no
beginning and cannot be divided because
there's no thing to divide I mean that's
when this one is you know it's fully
void-based
okay there's no boundary there's no
beginning or end there's the Eternal now
the omnipresent omniscient omnipotence
psychokinetic control over people can't
help but be completely peaceful in your
presence I mean
they you're just one one being you're
the verb
of everything
and with them and and they're when they
ordinarily might be completely terrified
and crazy
they're brought to Total peace
instantaneously just by being within a
quarter mile of you
right
yeah right and that's so that's that's
exactly the vision and that you and I
share that
yeah is Big Time
yes and I and I do want to
um
I want to also
supportively include the
um understanding of what Christ
represented at the same time as we
understand what Buddha represented
because
more and more
their emptiness and love are really two
sides of the same coin and for that
Christ being up on the cross
is equivalent to anata in Buddhism
to understand that there is no self and
the more that you hang your sense of
self your ego up on the cross
the more that you become space and love
to serve others in the world and so that
that's just I found to be the most
crucial because you can bring almost all
of the planet together with that style
of interpretation
understanding well that's exactly the
pivot the Eternal Pivot Point
of the uh of the 27 million dollar
project
is getting the whole of humanity because
there is no other everything else is an
artifice
that surrendered emptiness that gives
rise to our presence
is the only peaceful place in the whole
of existence
yeah
and when we consciously share that we
are Consciousness that that
Consciousness is the void that cannot be
divided
and we notice that
consciously
in a heartfelt fully embodied way
together
we realize what what gotama and uh in
Christ
were holding out for
you know
why Christ would submit himself to be
crucified for the for the Salvation of
humanity
that you know realize that you're all
crucifying yourselves I am you
you know and and so what is it that
transcends death I am that which
transcends death
who are you that transcends death who
are we that transcend death that are
deathless and uncreated and unborn which
is the Buddha in in the Hindus and the
the Atman you know Atman and the and the
anata are the two sides of the same coin
yeah
and from this
from this peace from this love
um
it's just all possible from here
um
heaven on Earth like we said yeah
yeah
that's exactly it is that we're
we are Heavenly We Are Spiritual we are
spirited and are there's nothing else
that is truly
meaningful except that which is uh
you know oddly enough meaning less
doesn't need to have a meaning
right and just the moments of just
just non-proliferation
stop weaving stop storytelling stop hype
games of identity and just
relax
just see what's left when you
deconstruct all those
habits of identity and of location and
comparison and measurements and all that
and
even just those little tiny glimpses
of what remains when all that is declung
from
that is healing and that is doing the
work in that
is just so nourishing for that
that underlying piece that just wants to
be
to what you want to feel in the union
avoidness you're feeling Union with it
but the primary attractor if you will is
to avoid it at all costs is like for the
mind to weeds endlessly so that it
doesn't dissolve into space
into its nature
and that
is just so beautiful the math the
physics the creativity the Ingenuity of
the universe
who is designed
it's unbelievable
well I've been working with this uh the
most I've looked for this most brilliant
physicist that could understand
and uh
discover
and model the
the physics of Consciousness because the
the
materialistic mechanistic uh scientific
military industrial political medical
establishment
it was very clear
45 years ago that
the only value that could really shift
them out of that
tyrannical totalitarian
[Music]
materialistic Focus was to
discover what Consciousness is in in
physics and describe it and that has
been achieved
over the last six years in great rigor
and depth uh it took me took this one 45
years or a lifetime to to do that and
so
working with this collaborating with
this man who's just a couple years older
than I am he is a
physics Professor for 35 years he's
written a hundred papers he's absolutely
outstanding in his Clarity he's a
scientific historian uh
the whole history the development of our
understanding of ourselves our attempts
to understand each other ourselves over
from the very origins of speech until
the present day he has chronicled that
with such Clarity it's amazing the sky
uh Ellen
and I read you something from one of
these testimonials you know I'm doing
these groups for 40 years
with Multicultural groups for you know
all over the world for 40 years Ellen
you know that right
right
here's duties he says um
our conscious conversation simply and
gently yet profoundly revealed the truth
that all of humanity has been seeking
forever
in just a few minutes
as Perry pointed our awareness to
awareness itself the illusion of
Separation began to dissolve
my sense of having a separate body
melted in the warm delicious energy that
engulfed the whole group
thoughts had no power and floated by
like clouds emotions transformed into
what I experienced to be the empty
fullness spoken of by the sages or
eternal love itself
the embodiment of what cannot be
adequately spoken of happened
it was Blissful and once experienced
nothing can or ever will be the same
this is life this is a life-changing
event
yeah this sounds beautiful this is you
know here is Jake John Jacob Zucker
Gardner who a professor of leadership at
Seattle University who assembled leaders
of all huge corporations maybe 20 years
ago brought them together at Stanford
University
he came to a group when we in Santa
Barbara maybe I don't know at least 15
20 years ago
uh just after that and
we had a group at 4 30 a.m in the
morning with 12 of us where we felt like
we could there was no separation between
any two atoms in our bodies and we were
so weightless that we literally felt
like we could jump into the air and fly
around like a like birds
okay so amazing
ecstasies and wow that shared so
indivisibly Alan oh my God and so John
said to me afterwards he said I always
knew it had something to do with sharing
undivided attention but it didn't quite
understand how to bring that into focus
and he had me up and introduced me to
um the grants one of the grandsons of
Mahatma Gandhi who I just happened to
sit down next to in one of the groups he
had arranged that he brought me up to
into the Northwest there um
and Mahatma Gandhi I mean
um garan Gandhi uh wanted me to do these
groups online to his 200 City Setters as
uh you know to you know bring people
into this state of non-violent
Consciousness like
Etc so here John says the remarkable
work of Sperry Andrews and the human
connection Institute and developing ways
to move people into Collective and
Global Consciousness is worthy of wide
recognition and attention as we move
from me to we Sperry's work will serve
as a Guiding Light to Collective
consciousness
so
you know there there is this level at
which we have to be the Atman we have to
be
someone doing something uh because the
nothingness is doing something by doing
nothing
it's make it's making all form all of
space-time energy and matter mind and
body indivisible every single moment
that you know the whether we're dead or
we're alive we're not dead we're we're
still
uh the awakeness that is eternal and
uncreated
so
in order to align the this neocortex
with the non-verbal body the sensory
motor reptile that's been eating and
being eaten for hundreds of millions of
years and the and what emerged and grew
out of that like a out of a seed
emerge the uh the the heart felt
uh mammalian limbic system to
um
to make it possible so that we could
have heard
s of mammals that could uh
survive and thrive better in the same
way that individual cells 1.6 billion
years ago in the in the Frac in the
fossil record now has been discovered
uh had already begun to uh to
collaborate with other single cells to
form multicellular organisms in the
fossil record
uh that the indivisibility of all things
has to
uh
foment this collaboration like you and I
Alan
it seems that you know we've been
birthing our individuality for some time
here whereas Bruce Lipton would say
we're
we are these zygotes that
have come together and there's 50
trillion human cells collaborating with
10 to 20 times as many bacterial cells
that are forming a single cut individual
individuating incomparably unique
Consciousness as Alan as Sperry sitting
here
and
that as we as individual human beings as
Carl Jung said in the process of
maturation we recognize that we are
indivisible from everyone and everything
inevitably
we have a chance of having a conscious
civilization on this planet
that you and I Alan in that we do
recognize our indivisibility and the
peace
the pure and total communion of
unconditional true love that we actually
in fact are together
that we cannot deny it any longer
that we're not losing a territory we've
survived by separating demarcating a
separate physical and psychological
territory
as as plants and animals for hundreds of
millions of years we have a habit that
we're hypnotized to to perpetuate
but by being so indivisible as a single
indivisible Consciousness we can
recognize that we don't have to go along
with our programming now
see what I'm saying yeah
and
the very
nature of it is to delude itself in all
of its programming
and to wake up from that to heaven on
Earth yes
that is unbelievable
yes it is
unbelievable it is the coolest you know
if you could what what more like is this
not a miracle
what really like what could be more of a
miracle I mean the the whole of this
universe are all by roots and count two
trillion galaxies
with hundreds of billions of suns in
each Galaxy and countless planets that
probably are have produced sentient life
billions of years ago that
the whole universe is the ET say the the
ebens so-called say that the universe is
a sole manufacturing facility
and so
the fact that we don't need to believe
anything because it's unbelievable
because belief is really not necessary
to recognize what we are
foreign
so the whole thing is that the cosmos
from being nothing at all
the void as one was we spoke of in
November of 2019 the void
in that it cannot avoid itself as being
dimensionless uh
can uh
be also known as every dimensionless
point in the potential of
three-dimensional reality which is just
the fluctuating relationship of
dimensionless points
and so we are the fluctuating
relationship or dimensionless points
that are held together by that which is
dimensionless that is the Observer of
three dimensions
foreign
ever amen
amen
yeah
right
there's actually a physics prize of five
physics prizes a thousand dollars each
that you and I could win together by
just offering this very video that we're
on right now to the that's the the
timing of it closes at the end of
October
and they want to have explications
through physics of Consciousness exactly
that because of course that's the most
pivotal
uh realization that has to be
articulated to the new brain that this
child the verbal analytic
new brain that is attempting to make a
conceptual map of what is non-verbally
sensed and felt
so that the body heart and mind as a
Triune brain in the brain there is a
Triune body heart and mind that is
represented here in this three pound
universe
and it's attempting to make an
equivalent of what is formless
completely and utterly formless and
immeasurable and indefinable and
unbelievable
right and
it's so
uh
alluring for the sense of self to avoid
being nobody nowhere
uh
nothing
uh without anything to achieve to be
peace to be space
is
what why why would the sense of self
ever want that when it's so happy in its
little Barbie house that it's
constructed or Ken house where it loves
believing in the idea of its own
identity being the body and comparing
itself and measuring itself to other
bodies and feeling lack
and we're just being incessantly
oriented towards its objective
external
reality what's what's the main mechanic
mechanism
that brings
Consciousness back to its own
no-buddiness and spaciousness and love
what is the mean one is it meditation is
it psychedelics is it Shadow work
Psychotherapy is it a conglomeration of
all of those things is it science and
spirituality merging together into a
grand Unity
what is it and how can you Shepherd that
well
it's I think with meditation and
contemplation and being honest with
ourselves we realize that unless we are
uh conscious of consciousness
we're overly identified with things and
thoughts and activities which
never satisfy never no matter what we
get a hold of you know the top down
Cadillac uh uh and the in the great
Gower guy
it really doesn't satisfy for very long
it in fact we we become honest
you know you know if we take Ayahuasca
we we're like our conscience is
magnified about a million times and we
realize that we've been totally lying to
ourselves that we're egocentrically
idiotic and that we're completely
miserable idiots
and so when you know the plants which
have been evolving a lot longer than us
let's say
they're in unity Consciousness in order
to survive and thrive in the exigencies
of nature of downpours and whatever
might be going on in nature
uh they have to adapt we're we're in our
little Caddis shells and our little
hovels going like oh you know huddling
to try to survive uh because we're
you know we're we're trying to invent
nature through us is attempting to
invent some new way of being because
everything at the level of form has to
be incomparably unique every moment
because form in order to be like
formlessness
has to through observational measurement
and quantum mechanics has to observe
itself to be what it appears to be
perceptually
and through that measurement structure
which is a spatial temporal energetic
and material mind-body structure
form the focus of the next observation
which transforms that spatial temporal
energetic material Mind Body measurement
into the next observation so there is
the evolution of observational
Consciousness as embodied By Us by you
and I and eight billion people in every
bug and leaf and creature on this planet
and we are the universe is expanding at
an Ever accelerating rate for that
reason as well the whole Cosmos is being
reinvented and that's the one of the
most amazing things about existence is
that
that the whole universe can be
incomparably unique continuously not
just incrementally it's a continuous
representation
deconstruction and representation of
itself taking place continuously it's
not contiguous moments
that one after the next after the next
that can appear that way but it's
actually that every dimensionalist point
in three dimensions is undivided they
share a single polar point
that we call the fourth dimension of
space which was suppressed when
James Clay Maxwell in the quaternium
theory William Clifford who died quite
early showed this
Colusa and Klein had a model that
Einstein almost used uh Louis de brogli
who I'm not pronouncing his name
properly said that every particle shared
a single uh singularity
that is omnipresent okay and when this
one talked with uh Nasim haramin on the
phone for the first time this was 10
years ago uh nothing what about what uh
de broglie said that uh there's a
there's all particles Shira one
Singularity said well I'd forgotten
about that yeah uh I'll have to look
back into that yes I agree that that the
whole universe shares a single
Singularity and so that Singularity
though is not is also at every single
dimensionalist point in the coordinate
locations of 3D which are how many
dimensionless points can there be in 3D
well there's more dimensionless points
in 3D than there are anything else in
the universe
there's there's a plethora of
dimensionless points that are all
sharing a single polar point that make
the whole universe an instantaneous
indivisible whole holographic Recreation
that is recreating itself through
consciousness
this awakeness that aspect of awareness
that like a mirror in our bathroom has
no image of its own it is choiceless
and so we have no image of our own
ultimately and we can ex learn to accept
that because we can understand it here
cognitively conceptually we can
understand how we are nobody going
nowhere forever and when we can finally
understand it conceptually with this new
child like
aspect that grew out of our reptile and
out of our mammal to be able to focus
awakeness
more precisely than our these fields of
emotions and Fields and Sensations could
ever possibly do
and so the conceptual brain can be used
the left brain primarily the left right
brain is largely mitigating the the
sensory and emotional non-verbal through
the vagus nerve to interface with this
new child of
conceptualizing consciousness
in some
precise very precise way to locate it
like where is this nothingness where is
this Observer that we all are how can we
all share a commonly sensed holy
heartfelt conscious intelligence forever
and ever amen and have Heaven on this
planet and have a go an enlightened
species-wide society that it lives in
joy an unconditional love every single
instant yeah
[Music]
so so wonderful to feel how the dust
settles from all that energy energetic
blah blah it just all the dust particles
just
fall to Earth and to nothingness
and we're at peace p-e-a-c-e all the
pieces fall together and the puzzle
all the puzzled pieces that are puzzle
puzzling to us they just effortlessly
and automatically all fall together and
represent the p-e-a-c-e
that we all know and love so dearly and
completely
[Music]
how could anything ever be
just
doing nothing and feeling absolute peace
and wholeness
[Music]
but modeling how to do it right now
wouldn't you say
yeah
this is the example that the
uh that science has been looking for the
objective evidence
that it's possible to
sense feel and think about that which is
thoughtless
that which is formless that which is
unmanifest
Nikola Tesla said that in one sentence
that when
science begins to study
the non-physical
non-material
aspect of reality that it will make more
progress in uh in a year than it has in
all the centuries of its past
something like that it's the exact quote
so it's not about setting aside the blah
blah it's it's realizing that the blah
blah is
is not only blah blahing it's also
utterly and completely silent and
immeasurable
and unknowable
simultaneously
that's the uh the Alpha and the Omega
the the void
and not avoiding itself
yeah it's uh musical notes and the space
and
yeah the musical notes are about heaven
on Earth
and peace and love and abundance and
prosperity
then
they're harmonious
it's one way of looking at it if they're
not
then they sound like nails on a
chalkboard
so why not just
the space
you love
be empty
and just allow
most harmonious
notes to just effortlessly and
spontaneously without a doer controller
just Express themselves
into generating even greater peace
love
Harmony
abundance
prosperity
yeah
and it's really cool actually Sperry I
like how
much you've
pieced together in the last couple of
years
the core of the spiritual wisdoms with
the core of the scientific wisdoms and
our
speaking to the synthesis of them
and it does feel like that's
very deeply at the core of uh
of also bringing
us all together is that because uh
there's a lot of
um
there's a lot of Reliance
um within the
Matrix on hey
what are scientists saying about
Consciousness right now
and that can be a really good gateway to
get people to care a little bit more
about meditation or about entheogens or
about
prayer and contemplation self-inquiry
Shadow work
Can't Break Free
from the chainless chains
unless you actually
deconstruct all of the illusions that
you're using
to hold yourself
in your sense of self
foreign
I'm glad you're on that and I am too and
uh it feels like we're more mature it
feels like we're more uh Rife and ready
for
collaborations and uh
Prosperity together and with our
networks and projects which is really
good so Sperry's been on uh D Hypno
de-hypnotizing uh would you like to
sure
I mean you already have it but
specifically the multimedia project and
well it was really struck Ellen uh
thanks for asking uh
that by there have been multiple
you know career
uh hypnotists that have come to the
groups
and have said variations of
you know Sperry you're de-hypnotizing
people
by bringing them into Unity
this indivisible Unity communion
uh and that really struck me that wow uh
yeah
the the challenge which is an enormous
challenge is to de-hypnotize humanity
how do you go about de-hypnotizing eight
billion people
who are at each other's throats
polarized against each other and
destroying the ecosystem of this planet
with the media being owned by the
havemeyer group and you know and by the
power elite who want to uh eliminate the
majority of us
so that they can have their own Garden
of Eden
and then they'll probably just they
don't know what else to do except to
kill each other
don't think that's going to work out too
well uh
so
you know they need to recognize uh how
to be free of that
vice grip
on controlling tyrannically
everybody else around them is as their
greater body heart and mind they have to
like I have to lose weight so I have to
get rid of uh
you know 95 percent of humanity
you know so they're just going about it
in their own kind of psychotic
sociopathic way and if we can have some
empathy for them and not make them the
enemy and polarize against them they
might actually feel that and not be so
fearful of us as the majority
for example
what do you say about that album
yes
yes yeah
isn't that what this is not what this is
really is when you're watching content
aren't you kind of being hypnotized by
the person that's speaking
at varying levels of hypnosis let's say
and if the hypnosis is around
deconstructing illusion into greater
Freedom isn't that what you seek
you know those
the best uh I mean so much of the great
work that's being done online uh by
presenters
is to expose the truth about
you know all the sort of craziness of
the genocidal initiatives that have been
in the pipeline for so many decades
uh and they're doing a great job and
that's a job that needs to be done
yet the addressing as we are here uh are
essential nature which is already
liberated
that cannot be destroyed and cannot be
dominated because there's nothing to
dominate
that is something that also needs to be
happening and I my sense is that Alan
you and I are innately bound to
collaborate
in this way that nature created us which
would obviously must have I mean did we
create ourselves
unless we are the void
uh regenerating itself as at the level
of form to expand
the incomparable uniqueness of every
moment because the void is incomparably
unique every moment
it forces form space and time energy
matter to be incomparably unique every
moment precisely because it serving as
the Observer that is reconnecting and re
deconstructing and representing
in this mirror of awakeness
it is utterly and completely unique it's
immeasurable and unknowable and
boundless and Timeless but it's it's an
eternal now
and that everything that is created by
this eternal now
has to be incomparably unique as well
there's no choice about it it's so it's
choiceless
and so if we choose to be choiceless
deliberately we are liberated into the
joy of being Consciousness itself
together
foreign
yeah
yeah
yeah
I have
so much
peace
and space that what is is just a mirror
for
the sense of self in another to
decontract
its delusions into the expanse of being
more like space and love and mirror
so
be free of your own delusions and
distortions so that your Reflections can
be very pure
pure reflections
even just
hugging
when the mind of other is proliferating
and just going and hugging
and kissing and loving just that
can be enough for the mind to see its
Illusions and to relax into greater
space and love
so many times words don't even
are needed
yeah
I'm really happy oh I think so Tooth
Fairy I feel so too there is a lot of uh
Synergy and play that's here that's
actualizing itself and it's uh it's
powerful it's blossomed a lot it's
matured and ripened a lot I keep feeling
this with very
specific special uh cases of
recontact and uh
yeah
it's funny because you also
simultaneously don't want to contact so
it's like
yeah but that's a whole nother thing
I'll make more content about that later
but what happens if you don't contact
any
sense data at all
what happens then
what are you left with well I think what
what I sense you're pointing to is what
happens in deep contemplative meditation
is the silence and the Stillness
that is the only
reality ultimately everything else is
temper real and never the same way twice
so there's a that which is the only
constant in the whole of Consciousness
becomes conscious of itself
and in that is the attractor it's like a
magnet it attracts
understandings and insights and
inventions and Creations that have never
happened before that are solutions to
the the deepest of all problems and are
the self-discovery of like who the heck
am I and who are we and where are we
going and why are we going there and
what
all that is revealed effortlessly and
spontaneously yes
[Music]
you know it without even asking it to be
revealed that we don't have to create
our own reality we are the most amazing
uh you know by doing nothing and making
no effort and beating nobody we are
regenerating
the phenomenology of of our forms and
minds and hearts and bodies and the
social matrices and we're renewing
ourselves completely
we're liberating ourselves on taking you
know the weakest link in the chain it
determines how strong the chain is and
the weakest link is the fact that
there's no chain
Sperry can you give us a existing list
of the uh most uh
the projects that you're giving your
most amount of time to and then listing
down from the top of the ones that are
most in uh especially for people to hear
about and potentially get involved in
and then we can put the links in the bio
also in the description
[Music]
well
you know it took from my near-death
experience at age four
where I existed without a body heart or
mind without any boundary and there was
no me it was just this
foreign
which was aware of itself as this
awakeness that is choiceless and
formless
that was quite an education
experiential education and so when the
one came back into this one's
four-year-old little boy body
asked
because this one was playing Zorro uh
when this tree limb fell on him
attempted to ask like
coming off of DMT
uh
when you try to ask a question and the
answer comes to you before you finish
asking the question was exactly like
that
and the answer came back and was shown
kinesthetically that everything
fluctuates in and out of form
and I this one saw Fields the whole of
nature fluctuating in and out of
formlessness
and being renewed and recreated
continuously
and so that this the first thought that
this one had as a four-year-old little
boy was
well why would zaro need to know this
because Zorro was trying to learn how to
save the day because of the double
suicides of my grandmother and
grandfather when I was two and four
uh my mother's father and mother
and I felt her grief but she wouldn't
share it with me and I was like I feel
her grief but why won't she share it
with me
I need to be Zorro to save the day so
here
this brought about this playing on this
this branch of a of a tree that had died
and this one at four knew nothing about
branches breaking and
rosaro ended up under the without going
into the whole thing I mean
this one has spent a lifetime figuring
out okay obviously this is
uh away
of making sense
of the whole
shebangenness of life
and that more people are having their
death experiences as of maybe 20 years
ago there were 10
million people just in the United States
alone that it had reported having
near-death experiences imagine what that
actually is on a worldwide level that
nature
as us is educating us through
showing us that we're nobody going
nowhere forever
and held magnificently beautiful that is
it's so joyful and when Eckhart Tolle
says you know make friends with the now
uh and he writes the book Stillness
Speaks
you know and and everything is is is
culminating towards us being able to
share a commonly sensed holy heartfelt
conscious intelligence
as an indivisible being
and these ATS are making contact to us
uh in the uh
like Emery Smith who was working
in these uh you know military
corporate
places east of Albuquerque and he'd
earned their respect and they said okay
we're going to introduce you to your
your your first ET Emery uh tomorrow
you'll meet him and he's an
interdimensional E.T he'll appear in
front of you
and so Emery figured out the 150
questions to ask this E.T because he was
like a young guy is being educated to be
a doctor through all these operations
and tissue samples and stuff of ETS and
so here's going to meet the CT and E.T
appears and answers his 150 questions in
under a second
telesomatically because when you share
you know somatic empathetic
conceptualizing Consciousness in an
integrated way as two people
you can't lie you're sharing what there
is that can be known and felt and sensed
and and notice
with another person even though you're
an ET from another race and the ET said
to him Emery look we know we've been
tinkering with you for hundreds of
thousands of years I mean there's a
quite a few different
Intergalactic civilizations that have
been messing around with you but you're
like our children we've been cultivating
you to be better than we've ever been
just like your children you want to be
to go beyond what you've ever have you
ever been and uh and so we are our
heroes uh Emery
and but even though you know you sense
that we're millions of years in advance
of you uh we're all equals it's only
because the billions of of of of people
in my civilization because we all share
an indivisible Consciousness consciously
in a fully embodied way together that
our
neurophysiological psychology is is is
millions of years in advance of yours
but that doesn't make us better than you
and so Emory's like he's smelting and
melting and melting in the love of this
extraterrestrial he can barely stay
standing he he feel he can see himself
falling to his knees and being
completely and utterly just disin
regulated by being love itself with this
beautiful person this entity in front of
him for heaven's sakes that is inside of
him inside of him with every intimacy
that
you know the subatomic level
you know what I'm saying so it's knowing
this experience is the teacher shared
experience is the teacher and so over
the last 45 years I've finally realized
45 years ago
there must be a way that I'm being shown
to bring people to this shared
experience
intimacy of being indivisible awake
aware sentience
and that you know this that the whole
Cosmos is on its way
in a path of evolution from nothingness
to being fully sentient as spatial
temporal energetic material mind
embodied beings
and here we are
uh and so I put together ultimately all
my 45 years of of clinical empirical
research that was replicated by multiple
Laboratories around the world that I
wanted to I set out back in 1988 with Dr
William broad who was the senior
research associate at the Mind Science
Foundation to see uh with I mean he was
award-winning psychophysiologist I mean
he's one of the most astounding
researchers that was heralded and
award-winning and and people would you
know dear a friends were people like
Russell targon and Harold put off and Ed
May who were given the millions of
dollars by the United States federal
government to compete with the Russian
Research into parapsychological remote
viewing and uh and being able to know
the future before it happened uh under
empirical conditions
um with double-blind studies so uh Dr
William broad became like closest friend
when I first met him physically and shot
in front of him when I traveled there
across the United States to be in San
Antonio Texas at the mine signs
Foundation I was finally there sitting
in front of Dr William broad he was so
peaceful I couldn't stop crying I just
was like weeping for Joy it was like oh
God this man is amazing and for five
years we worked together he said Sperry
you're like another Christian murty you
know you've what you're doing uh you
know I'll put you in touch with all the
top researchers in the field of
Consciousness and
this project that you want to do which
replicates what you and I have done
together uh with these cohorts of you
know 30 people that you TR one of which
you trained to share a commonly sensed
Consciousness to be tested after the
first group that was not
didn't go through your training and they
reversed from being made nervous when
noticed when they had no known way of
knowing when they were being noticed
over close circuit camera monitor system
while their bodies were being measured
with galvanic skin response uh
which William broad was a master of it
was like an extension of his body he was
able to find how people were reacting to
the most subtle uh you know cues and and
and
differentiations that were occurring in
their environment with other people
and so it was found that those people
who were
wanted to be with other people but they
were made nervous by being with other
people that when they were stared at
over closer camera monitor systems where
they could have no other known way of
knowing when or if they were being
stared at those are the people that were
most activated
and we had all this clinical evidence to
show that attention can be used as the
stimulus just like touching your nose as
a stimulus and you know I know that my
finger is touching my nose that my
paying attention to you
when you have no known way of knowing
when or if that's happening when we're
separated under the shielded
electromagnetic shielding conditions
that when I pay attention to you in an
undivided way you feel it even if you
don't consciously know it because you're
you're you're
uh your nervous system responds to my
attention just like a reptile walking
into the into a new Glade out of its
home
in the silence and Stillness of its
presence no consents whether there are
other Predators ready to pounce on it
from behind some Bush
we had to grow and develop that capacity
in order to survive okay even Sigmund
Freud as conservative as he is he said
the telepath telepathy somatic telepathy
was innate to us as animals that that's
the only way we could actually survive
and that that was suppressed as we
entered into verbal analytic
conversations and gave most of our
undivided attention to who we think we
are and what we think we're doing at a
verbal analytic level and the sensory
the silence
the field of sensory intelligence and
the field of emotional intelligence
which makes up 97 of our
moment-to-moment Consciousness
77 percent of our embodied intelligence
is being suppressed by this child that's
saying
to the heart which is like it's Mommy
and the body the reptile which is like
its daddy which is like
conditional love and the heart is like
the unconditional love of the mother
saying mommy daddy what's this what's
that give me a label for what I'm
conceptually experiencing non-verbally
with with you both
and so we have this growth incrementally
over hundreds of millions of years uh
emergent and here we are right now in
this eternal now
discovering what has been recreated out
of absolutely nothing whatsoever to be
us
and beholden to serve the greater good
of all life everywhere in the cosmos by
being peaceful and all loving in the and
recognize and respect this communion of
indivisibility of being
and so the the 27 million dollar
multimedia partnership proposal
offers offered to all of you who are
hearing this right now please let us
join together
in collaboration to serve our greater
purpose
of bringing about an enlightened
civilization on this planet
whatever it is that we each uniquely are
capable of doing to contribute to the to
our Awakening let's do it from this
moment onward
and so all the physics that have been
brought together all the physicists and
biologists and neuroscientists and
sociologists and psychologists that I
brought together over the last 45 years
all the tens of thousands of people that
have come to these groups
let us all come together now
and step into this
you know Heavenly place this eternal now
where we cannot die we are as they say
you know
in the ancient Hindu and buddhic and
contemplative Traditions that when we
recognize in life
who and what we truly are that when we
physically die we don't die we realize
that we are deathless
and the afterlife has been studied by a
friend of mine here who is a was
introduced to me by my physics partner
who's spent 50 years studying the
afterlife written 22 books
and these people like William James who
was one of the top people 100 years ago
has communicated through Jane
um
his name who wrote Seth speaks Jane
Roberts
uh
William James contacted after he was
dead contacted Jane Roberts and said I
want to publish a book I want to channel
the book through you and she she
recognized it and honored it and did
that and some of the most magnificent
understanding of the afterlife of what
it is to be ten thousand times as joyful
it'd be ten thousand times as agonized
about how unconscious and insensitive we
were on the Earth plane
how that unfolds and how we take
responsibility
as that which cannot suffer for how
crazy we've been here and so we continue
to learn and unlearn and and
are born again
every instant passing
and we're all doing this
it's so fantastic it's like a rave where
we're all on uh you know MDMA
when I met Sasha Shogun for the first
time the fellow who put together MDMA
with his wife
and I was introduced to by one of my
dearest friends
and I stepped into his Aura he's a big
guy it was like stepping into the cosmos
I literally saw
stars and planets in vast empty space
and I felt utter and complete peace in
his presence and that I shared as one
single no nobody with him and with pure
love
Sasha shulga was amazing man who you
know created MDMA so that we could all
learn and use it as a stepping stone
into our Immortal nature
so this 27 million dollar multimedia
partnership proposal that
involves feature and documentary films
which bring audiences through by
breaking the fourth wall bringing them
into a commonly sensed holy heartfelt
conscious intelligence with the people
on screen who are already anchored in
this indivisibility and we end up
in let's say in one example a stadium of
sixty thousand people like giant Stadium
and there are multiple cameras recording
this that are put together to make the
film uh the 90 to 120 minute film and
various clips of that
where people in the audience are brought
into Unity Consciousness by the people
in the new thought movement and the
Consciousness movement in a circle
people like Eckhart Tolle and Deepak
Chopra and and Marion Williamson and so
forth at Center Stage who are sharing
what they're sensing and feeling
together in an undivided way as a
greater body heart and mind with sixty
thousand other people
and those people at home who are
watching maybe just as indivisible
individuals and we see them on the film
too because we're recording those people
and some groups are are being actually
psychophysiologically for their
autonomic and central nervous systems
being recorded simultaneously we see
them in the film and so like the Beatles
created the first simulcast when they
sang uh all there is is love or you know
love is all there is uh that was the
first simulcast on the planet Earth we
have the first simulcast of this film uh
sharing the indivisibility of our
commonly sensed Consciousness as a
species on this planet to make it
experientially plausible that we can be
safe and secure by embracing
are are infinite immeasurable depth and
beauty
as consciousness
as joy as Eckhart Tolle would say we are
the you know the joy of being is the joy
of being Consciousness together
so that's the basically the Aegis of the
project is to use social media to make
it available around the clock in
multiple languages for free as a free
membership at any time of the day or
night just click a button and you can be
there with total strangers or groups
that you create
for free and enter into this commonly
sensed common sense it's a common it's
like we all leaders in the whole of
history have said please people use your
common sense and and what is common
sense telling us right now
it tells us
that we're already free and we just need
to
to notice it and feel it and share it
indivisibly forever and ever amen as
love itself well as Christ Consciousness
as
the Atman as the anata as the no self
and as the one self as as all selves uh
knowing what we are forever and ever and
ever have been and ever will be an
ever-present
spirited
you know all the indigenous cultures
who
say the great spirit is everything it is
everyone it is all that ever has been
and ever will be and is now and so all
the indigenous cultures are included
here uh indivisibly and we are all
Awakening to our combined wisdom
and the wisdom come through our sh the
wisdom of humanity as Bruce Lipton said
years ago with being interviewed by Alan
um
uh his last name will come to me in a
moment uh Steinfeld
Bruce Lee said you know we you know
Nature has created us to be like you
know out of zygotes to be multiple
zygotes functioning as a single
consciousnesses and when
all human beings realize that they're
just cells like zygotes or cells in us
we are cells in the body of humanity
when Humanity can speak as one
humanity is one sentient
Consciousness with other Ascension
consciousnesses from other uh
Intergalactic civilizations then we will
be allowed into uh and become part of
this commonly sensed Consciousness
either uh
you know within this solar system and
with within this Galaxy with hundreds
and thousands of other extraterrestrial
or inner terrestrial civilizations and
we will join this Cosmic sentient
Recreation and uh the one as
um
uh
and his name is going to escape me he
says you know what there's as with the
ETS that uh you know that we are there's
only one people here in this universe
uh you know there's only one of us how
many uses can there be
you know there's only one life one
nature one Cosmos one unified verse and
we are it together
so all of this cognition all these
labels all these sticky notes we don't
need to make our mirrors opaque with
things and thoughts and activities that
that occlude the ability to receive and
reflect yeah here we are on this
two-dimensional screen on Zoom
it's you know the most advanced
physicists uh like Sussman
suscon
at Stanford you know creating the
holographic model that the whole
three-dimensional reality can be reps
represented in two-dimensional service
here we are represented under
two-dimensional surface on Zoom we we
are a three-dimensional hologram being
represented on our two-dimensional
surface which is a mirror-like meeting
place
which is essentially a dimensionless
meeting place
made out of dimensionless points that
are you know when you take
two points you have a line
before that you just have a point you
have two points make a line three points
make a plane a two-dimensional surface
wait a minute forget it where's this
instead of just one over here
okay you get four points and you turn
them
so they're orthogonal or perpendicular
to each other you now have the first
three-dimensional volume you have a
tetrahedron which is the strongest
structure in nature and we see in the
actual uh you know quantum mechanics of
probability fields and in the biology of
particles uh or the quantum mechanics of
particles and the biology of cells and
so forth there is this res this
resonance structured it is ubiquitous
that is fundamental to form
and we can begin to recognize all these
things and so the conceptual mind
becomes satisfied we have to satisfy the
conceptual mind yeah so that it can work
with these the the field of
indivisible field of Sensations and the
indivisible field of emotions this
so there is this bicameral
left and right brain the right brain
representing the part in the body
through the vagus nerve connected
throughout the body and it's it's trying
to come into this relationship with this
conceptualized new feature this child
which is reaching for some way of
creating a conceptual aversion
of what is non-verbally felt and sensed
and that's all we have to just
contribute to that
in whatever way we can every moment
consciously
yeah and we will know who would what are
know our purpose and serve it uh
joyfully together
and so that's the mission and Ethos of
both the connection Institute but also
the 27 million dollar multimedia
partnership proposal yes
excellent and so the best way for people
to engage with that is like you said
just be right here engaged with your own
direct experience of Awakening but also
is to check out the I have it pulled up
and I'll have it in the
in the description below so is it uh
both
connectioninstitute.org but also for the
uh proposal it's the de-hypnotizing
humanity proposal that is up there right
that's right I I have all those in the
description of other that I can just
paste in the description of this video
awesome okay nice nice and by the way I
was mentioning this to Sperry also that
the fourth wall
is a very beautiful even right now
that's what we're doing
this is it like this right here
this is talking to the audience
right and so if the people
that are talking to each other like this
are Anchored In Love
and space
and then
something happens there that's beautiful
noteworthy and the cast turns to the
audience
and engages them how do you guys feel
right now after that beautiful shift
you know that kind of stuff like after
that decontraction how does that make
you feel and so now we're really in the
territory of advanced media I think
breaking the fourth wall is one of the
most beautiful ways to bring forth
Advanced media and linking up through
content creation it's super exciting
stuff Sperry all about it it's so
exciting that this has been trying to
break through that as I said that you
know Lewis to broke we and
closer and Klein and James Clerk Maxwell
and um
all pointed to this fourth dimension of
space not time
that instantaneously United all points
in 3D but in the Solvay conference
uh the conservative element said no we
can't measurement measure it and lo and
behold it's because it's immeasurable
there's nothing to measure
and so the conservative elements said
well we can't measure it so it can't be
considered physics
and they threw it out
and if they had accepted it Einstein
would have made the fourth dimension of
uh time the fourth dimension of
space-time because time is The Observer
of space
time is timelessness
making the whole of space and
instantaneously indivisible
it's the Observer
it's The Unborn uncreated deathless
awakeness that is choiceless and
formless
that is causing form to reform and
become more and more like formlessness
so that
slowly but surely our forms our bodies
hearts and minds are becoming as
flawlessly in
indivisible from what all that we are at
the level of form as formlessness is
indivisible from formlessness
so we are becoming more like the void at
the level of form which is really
enlightened Consciousness now to inform
and formlessness where here they are
here's formlessness here's form and they
cannot exist without each other without
formlessness
form would not have independent
interconnected attributes that can move
independently of each other it all
depends on the form utilizing this
indivisibility of formlessness
and so like uh because they are one
without a second
in the phase transition between
formlessness and form
and I explained this of course when we
were speaking and meeting back in uh in
November of 2019
that in the phase transition like
between water and ice or water and gas
the phase transition between these
absolute opposites I mean nothing could
be more opposite than formlessness and
form but in the phase transition that
unites the two
what is that that is consciousness that
is this but not that
that's like you know Nettie Nettie not
this not that it is this but not that it
is it is this but but not that
that is what is the
anata and the ottman simultaneously
it's you and me you're there's you and
there's me it's not
that I
you know occlude or you know
overarchingly take precedence over you
that's like a very mechanistic
materialistic
sociopathic model of like who's going to
eat who here who's going to you know
who's gonna do the eating and and who's
going to do the loving let's say you
know who's going to be the lover are you
going to be the woman or am I going to
be the woman are you going to be the man
am I going to be the man you know it's
all this polarization to just forget you
know let that all be what it is
because between the gender war between
men and women when they can be share a
commonly sensed holy heartfelt fully
embodied awake where Consciousness that
is conscious of itself then they can
have unconditional
eternal love and have marriages that
last and have children that are brought
up in the indivisible unconditional love
of their parents so children from the
when they're first born and they come in
like
they're not afraid of anything they
nature creates us when we're newborns to
be lit up and turned on we're lit up
we're so excited to be what we are and
we're not afraid of not knowing who we
are we're completely ignorant and
innocent utterly and completely
you know when I had my son I could hold
him in my on my arm with his head in my
palm of my hand and Roar him around in
the air uh recklessly uh you know but
securely he had no fear at all he had no
concept of fear
so we can bring up children on this
planet with through our communion with
them as Consciousness itself with no
fear
so we're not traumatized by being
objectified as good little girl good
little boy this is your mommy that's
your daddy this is this your that's your
that
this is your sister's toy give it back
to your sister eat your oatmeal or I'll
slap you or I'll make you wrong or make
you feel that you as a separate object
is my little boy or whatever you know is
not behaving the way I want you to and
that kind of blame and that kind of
Shame and that kind of tyrannical
control over us as if we're a subject
separate subject upon on the chessboard
of life is absolutely traumatizing from
the get-go and when we could grow up on
this planet without being treated as
objects
and we were not taught to treat our
mothers and fathers and our caregivers
as objects
we can feel this object less Heaven
Heavenly unity and indivisibility of our
being with everyone and everything
continuously and we can have a healthy
civilization
that can abide in Joy Forever After
beloved Sperry
so
let's
I feel good about this
convo I feel like we can
pause the recording and we can publish
this and we can
share it and
galvanize
greater movement
for being present to
one's own Awakening right now and also
contributing uh to the connection
Institute in any way by seeing the
resources and checking out the
multimedia project proposal and
uh I would like to hear like I'll put
the link to the first uh conversation
also in the description and if you guys
want to go and check that out too the
one that we did three years ago that's
really cool
um and uh let us know also what you
think about this one I'd love to hear
from you
um comment below share it with those
that you feel like it would resonate
with like it subscribe all that good
stuff
um
yeah any uh any closing uh thoughts
before we pause the recording Sperry uh
I'm just listening to our recording from
three years ago last night and uh I
wanted to suggest as I have to some
from about
about a minute and a half to 32 minutes
is the core of the physics being shared
and felt and embodied by both of us so
that's if you just listen that long it's
a long long recording we kind of get
into all kinds of stuff later on that
I
kind of gets combabulated and jumbled a
bit because we're touching on all these
things and but that first 32 minutes is
really uh
well worth reviewing
nice
perfect
all right uh love you guys thanks for
tuning in and uh
just infinite love and light peace you
know
disparity yeah big hug and uh bye for
now